welcome back to Long crime daily
everybody the Florida sheriff's deputy
accused of hiding instead of taking
action during the Parkland school
shooting five years ago was in court on
Monday motions in the trial of Scott
Peterson were heard on Monday with jury
selection expected to start on Wednesday
17 people were killed at Marjory
Stoneman Douglas High School in Parkland
Florida Peterson was heavily criticized
for running away instead of helping he's
charged with child neglect and culpable
negligence one of the issues at hand
before the start of trial is whether the
jurors will be able to visit the school
building where the mass shooting
happened the fence says they should see
the outside of the building to help
understand Peterson's argument that he
was taking quote tactical cover
prosecution says if the jury goes to the
school they should also be able to view
the inside of multiple buildings to see
where Peterson was in relation to where
the murders were happening the state and
defense made their arguments on Monday
and the judge will decide the issue at a
later date here's what they had to say
when we went for a viewing of the scene
that was the first time I ever thought
my goodness not only do I want the
jurors to go there they need to go there
I couldn't imagine from all the photos
and all the videos that I've seen and
all the photos and videos I've seen
since going
how magnificently large the 1200
building is it's literally 73 yards long
three quarters of a football field it's
almost impossible to imagine from the
west side door to the east side door
which is where my client was he was on
the east side when he first heard shots
Aaron Feist was shot on the west side at
225.25
the distance between the two positions
is so extraordinary the only way to
appreciate that is to physically be
there there's allegations from the
defense that no we don't know where the
shots are coming from we don't know
um there's an echo there's sniper fire
there's all these different things the
defense has brought up and there's no
way the jurors can put two and two
together they can't get the spatial
differences without seeing it because
once you see the videos well they they
do show a certain small piece of what
was happening but they don't show the
thicker picture and there's no way for
the jurors to be able to analyze those
videos in their own heads as to what's
going on outside they have to see the
whole thing
well a motion that the judge did rule on
was a request to delay the trial the
defense wanted to push the trial back by
75 days because many of the witnesses
may have summer plans the judge denied
that request so Brian how important is
it for the defense to win this motion
that would allow the jury to go to the
school Jesse I think it's extremely
important based on what we're hearing
there are arguments not only from the
argument of tactical position because if
the defendant is on the opposite side of
the building a very large building and
he's supposed to be able to navigate
where this sound is coming from a
pronounced Echo as a defense is saying
would be very helpful and how do you
argue an echo how do I explain to 12
people that someone standing here
hearing something happening over there
would hear this it's extremely difficult
to do it with photos and video and so I
think if your argument is going to hold
water you've got to be given a cup and I
think the cup here is allowing people to
experience because videos and photos are
only part of our ability to understand
the world around us and appreciate and
understand an argument like this so if
they lose yeah sure make the argument
but I don't think people are going to
really connect with that information
maybe not buy that information and it
could be the difference between a guilt
and a not guilty verdict well Terry look
the defense is arguing that Peterson was
only a school resource officer he was
not part of the SWAT team I'm curious if
you think that's a good argument and
also if he ends up getting convicted how
is that going to impact other school
resource officers around the country you
know I think it is a good argument I'm
not saying it's going to Prevail but I
think they need to make the argument he
was trained before he got to that
position but SWAT officers are really
trained to deal with very dangerous
situations they are arguing that he was
only trained to deal with some
situations and he did have some active
shooter training now at the end of the
day since he is being charged with that
culpable negligence he's going to have
to show that what he did was reasonable
under the circumstances here a person in
his position and whether or not he a
duty to those students to go into the
classroom and I think the jury is going
to be very important here they're going
to put themselves in their own positions
if it was those children that were their
children and I think they're going to
say he should have gone in I think a lot
of eyeballs will be on this trial moving
forward another high profile news we now
have body cam footage showing the
aftermath of a crash caused by former
Las Vegas Raiders wide receiver Henry
rugs III rugs pleaded guilty earlier
this month to being drunk when he hit
another car going more than 150 miles an
hour
[Music]
all right we got a block that
intersection
[Music]
anyone inside the vehicle
control 449 the vehicles completely on
fire
[Music]
hey who's in this vehicle
foreign
another trial involving a former NFL
player starts this week in Florida the
27 year old is facing murder charges for
killing a man outside of his home after
a brawl Witnesses say Travis Rudolph got
into a physical fight with his
girlfriend Dominique Jones in April of
2021 that's when Jones reportedly texted
her brother to bring a group of men to
Rudolph's house to confront him
investigators say a fight eventually
broke out between Rudolph his brother
and the four men allegedly sent by Jones
prosecutors argue that Rudolph shot at
the group as they were leaving the
property killing 21-year-old Sebastian
John Jacques another member of the group
was reportedly injured and taken to the
hospital Rudolph tried to get the case
to Smith through Florida's stand your
ground law claiming self-defense but the
judge denied his argument siding with
the prosecution's claim that the men
were already retreating Rudolph faces
life in prison if convicted on all
charges
and we're finishing Today's Show with a
shocking story out of Indiana a
three-year-old accidentally shot two
people last week and it led to the
arrest of a wanted murder suspect police
say the shooting happened at an
apartment complex in Lafayette the
toddler got a hold of a gun and shot one
round towards his mother and her friend
they were both hit and treated at a
hospital for non-life-threatening
injuries but it turns out that the
mother's friend was 23 year old Trey
Song trayshawn Smith a wanted murder
suspect in the neighboring state of
Illinois after Smith left the hospital
he was taken into police custody local
departments in both Indiana and Illinois
are working together on Smith's arrest
still unclear how the three-year-old got
access to a gun and what type of gun it
was but so far no arrests or charges
have been made pending additional review
by the prosecutor's office Terry
how does a three-year-old get a hold of
a gun and figure out how to shoot it
shouldn't the mother have taken some
kind of precautions here you think she
really should have as it turns out this
gun was unlocked and it was loaded and
that is how the child got access to the
gun and believe it or not even toddlers
have the strength to pull the trigger on
a gun I did a little bit of research and
there are 4.6 million kids living in
homes with guns and sadly it's the
leading cause of death for children
under the age of 18. you might remember
that case in Indiana where we had that
four-year-old boy who was in a hallway
he had a gun and also the Virginia case
with the six-year-old who had a gun and
shot his teacher so it's all across the
country that this is happening now what
the American Academy of Pediatrics is
saying you should keep the guns outside
of your house all together so initial
Ted maybe or a tool shed maybe and you
should also if you keep it in the house
house you should make sure that it is
locked and it is unloaded that
ammunition should be kept separately
from the gun altogether if you can do
those things and teach your children
about gun safety and staying away from
and then perhaps we will not have as
many deaths as we're seeing now with
kids who are under 18 and other people
who are injured okay so that's that's
good advice now Brian the murder suspect
arrested what could happen to the
three-year-old and his mother though
well Jesse for the mother as as Terry
was outlining it all depends on the
condition or the way that the gun was
stored if she left it in a negligent way
that a three-year-old could stumble
across and grab which based on the
results it seems like that's what she
did she could face child neglect
negligency charges even probably the
assault of the suspect or the man with
the warned taishan Smith she could be
facing charges in relation to him now
the three-year-old does not have the
men's Ray or the mental capacity to know
right from wrong they're not getting
charged but if I'm that three-year-old's
child I'm definitely curious did Smith
have any kind of reward that if he got
caught or brought in can the
three-year-old collect that no no maybe
I go to a future tuition fund maybe I
don't know about that Brian Terry thank
you so much everyone out there thanks
for joining us here on Long crime daily
we're going to see you next next time as
we discuss Justice in America
[Music]